okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about future of Science
and Technology
I see we have a whole bunch of questions
saved up here so let me try to address a
few of these
uh
question here from Paula what's there to
say about the future of neural Nets
you know neural Nets are an interesting
episode in the history of science I
think I've talked about these a bit uh
in these live streams before but you
know neural Nets the way they're
currently the way they're kind of
conceived originated in 1943 this idea
of having this kind of collection of
neurons that each have a value and where
the value gets updated by having other
neurons connected to it and then having
certain weights with which they're
connected and having some kind of
activation function for each neuron to
determine how the the values will be
added up with the weights and then used
to determine the new value of the next
neuron down the line that idea
is from 1943 and modern neural Nets
pretty much using that idea now they've
been uh the the the thing that's
happened is
one could at first think about
oh every neuron is connected to or which
neurons is it connected to and the Brain
which is sort of the inspiration for all
of this a single neuron might be
connected to 10 000 or more other
neurons there's sort of a question of
how do you organize those connections
and I suppose a couple of the
Innovations have happened over the years
have been involved with that so
convolutional neuron that's led to sort
of big Advance around uh well the
convolutional neuron that's have been
used earlier but but the the sort of big
advance that happened around 2012 and
image recognition was using
convolutional neural Nets
um convolutional neural Nets say well
let's imagine that at least some layers
of neurons are arranged in some kind of
spatial fashion so that a particular
neuron is dealing with a particular part
of let's say the visual field and the
next neuron over is dealing with another
part of the visual field arranged in
this kind of spatial way
the thing that sort of the the big
innovation for uh things like Chachi BT
are so-called Transformers
and the main idea there tends to be in a
convolutional neural net you say there's
a neuron here and it's connected to some
neighboring neurons on the on the
previous layer it's it's gets its new
value from values of a a neighborhood a
geometrical neighborhood of neurons uh
previous neurons
but it's sort of a limited size of of
neighborhood so it's all kind of
geometrically local
the idea in Transformers is to have
something where typically it's it's
one-dimensional to have something where
the new value can depend on lots and
lots of previous values but the
weighting of those previous values and
the sequence is determined in some way
is learned in some way and that's it's
kind of the uh the notion is you have
something which isn't isn't precisely
local but for example it only looks at
things kind of earlier in the sequence
and so on uh so-called causal attention
mechanism
so these are you know these are sort of
particular methods of how to organize
the connections of of neural Nets uh in
neural Nets there have been other
Innovations things like normalization
layers and pooling layers and other
kinds of things like this they've been
there's been lots of kind of uh thinking
about how best to do how best to
organize training and so on there's been
sort of uh oh yes there are slightly
better activation functions that you can
use the the early ones tended to just be
if the total value was below zero make
the new value be zero and if it was a
band above zero make the new value be
one uh you know different different
approaches have been have been used
there
so but the I would say that the the
things that have led to uh the the lots
of details that have have allowed neural
Nets to be trainable and to not kind of
just wander off and uh and and and and
not be able to be set up to do the
things that one wants them to do the
things that have led to many of the of
the uh for example the chat gbt advances
I think have more to do with sort of the
the how to at a large outside the neural
net how to kind of set things up so that
the neural net kind of stays on track
and achieves the task you wanted to
achieve
I think if we say well what's the future
of all of this uh you know there will be
a bunch of engineering details which
will be tweaked and understood better
over the course of the last decade
several decades there's been sort of
steady Improvement in kind of noticing
oh if you do this if you don't let the
weights go out of it if you don't get
the values go out of control in this way
you do better if you if you uh uh
connect only these things you'll do
better and so on engineering details
which are important in terms of whether
the thing can actually work or not I
think that's one thing the other thing
is tremendous uh potential in sort of
how you actually put that underlying
neural net inside the actual task you're
trying to do
in terms of what will be kind of the the
big advances it's kind of shocking how
small the advances in some sense looked
at in sort of the big picture have been
over the course of decades it's mostly
been more data better understanding of
use cases and so on and the realization
that sort of if you just train the thing
and Bash it hard enough you can make it
do all these tasks which one just didn't
know before and didn't know that one
could get neuron that's to do pretty
good image recognition when didn't no
one could get no one that's through
pretty good speech to text one thought
one had to break those problems down
into lots and lots of carefully
engineered subcases rather than just
throwing the whole problem at neural
Nets and kind of bashing the neuron
that's hard enough with training data
so
I think that's um uh the the you know
there'll be technical advance in how to
make neural Nets learn fast to do better
Etc I suspect there are some bigger
things there are some things where for
example language models make use of lots
of sort of facts about the world they
don't really need the details of those
facts about the world inside the neural
net model those are things that can be
factored out delegated to well typically
our technology with both man from both
language and so on and the sort of
computable knowledge that we have there
that doesn't need to be all mixed in in
a in a way where neural net isn't even
very good at dealing with that to the
whole structure of the neural net the
neuron that can really be dealing just
with Linguistics and Common Sense and
not with detailed data or computation
with John that's aren't really directly
able to do
now you know people have tried to say
let's add little extra bells and
whistles to neural Nets let's add some
computation capability to neural Nets
and so on let's make it possible for
neural Nets rather than just sort of
interpolating their data and finding the
output based on that let's let the
neural net actually sort of do
computation right there inside the
neural net what seems to be emerging
right now is that what neural Nets and
language models and so on are pretty
good at doing is formulating what they
want to do so formulating okay we're
going to use this computation tool now
go off and just use that tool externally
rather than trying to burn that into the
inner to the neural Nets they've been
attempts to do that but there tends to
be this big trade-off between how
capable computationally do you want the
neural net to be and how trainable is
the neural net by the time the neural
net has more diversity and what it can
internally do it becomes extremely much
more difficult to train the neural net
and the various attempts over the last
decade particularly or so to make sort
of more computation inside the neural
Nets have tended to lead to less
trainability and less Effectiveness that
the tasks that neural Knights seem to be
good at doing
now you know there are some Clues we get
from the brain I mean people used to say
oh these artificial neural Nets are very
idealized models of how the brain works
you know there's there's a lot different
things happening in the brain as these
artificial neural Nets succeed in doing
so many more of these tasks that we
thought were very brain-like tasks like
language generation it seems much more
that we can learn things about brains
from artificial neural Nets and that's
something that's that's happening now
but still there are Clues from brains
about how we could sort of Go in
different directions when you're on that
one important feature is that in
something like chat GPT uh the that's a
pure sort of feed forward type Network
when it's running you know it's
generating the next word how does it do
that well it looks at all the previous
words it turns those into numbers it
feeds all those numbers through the
neural Nets and uh and comes out with
the probabilities for the next word then
picks the next word and then iterates
that whole process
but so just it just sort of feeds
through the network forwards
now there's the question right now sort
of training is a very separate thing for
neural Nets from this kind of uh actual
execution of the neural net actual use
of the neural net in brains we seem to
intersperse sort of learning and doing
much more than current neural Nets do it
and possibly that's because in brains
neurons are both places where memory
gets stored stored and places where
computations get done those are sort of
those are happening at the same time in
the same place so to speak and even the
very early models of neural Nets back
from the 1940s and so on had this idea
that there would be sort of memory and
uh and doing sort of all mixed together
but the actual engineering of neural
that's hasn't tended to do that it's
tended to be the case that there's sort
of a separate this is the place where
activity is happening separate from this
is the place where we're storing the
data presumably there will be ways found
to merge that and to do some more of the
things that are more brain like in that
regard and uh another thing is that
there's this whole question of sort of
how how the Dynamics of the neural
networks whether it's just oh you feed
forward through the network and get your
results and maybe you do that over and
over again but it's kind of a very
coarse kind of overall architecture for
how information flows through and on
that as opposed to things happening
inside the neural net in some much more
Dynamic way as I say the attempt to sort
of mix training with those kinds of
dynamic things has not been particularly
successful but one suspects that there
are probably things which involve sort
of more dynamism in neural Nets than
these kinds of workflows that just say
feed in an image get out the caption
from the image being in a caption get
out the image you know feed in text
continue that text and so on there are
probably more Dynamic kinds of things
that involve more sort of explicit
timely evolution of neural Nets rather
than just this sort of neuron that's
more like functions where you have input
crunch crunch crunch output type thing
you know I think that there are lots of
things about the neural nets for example
the fact that neural Nets use real
numbers to represent the strength of
sort of neural excitation at each neuron
in the neural net that's probably not
ultimately necessary uh people try
experiments with sort of less and less
precise numbers and neural Nets seem to
keep working just fine it's much more
difficult to do training because
training tends to involve incremental
changes in those numbers and if those
numbers are discrete it's much less
obvious what it means to make
incremental changes so you might train
with something with precise sort of
Fairly precise real numbers floating
Point numbers on a computer or something
and then try and distill that down to
something which has much less precise
numbers for when you're actually going
to run with that neural net but you know
there's a sort of big outstanding
question I've been interested in for a
really long time of whether one can make
things like cellular automata where
every cell value has is discreet feet
maybe it only has two possible values or
something whether one can do neural net
like things and do training kinds of
things on systems like that I I
investigated this back in the early
1980s didn't make too much progress with
it but I have to say I suspect it's
something where with kind of modern uh
sort of willingness to bash these
problems and these training problems
with just uh vast numbers of trillions
quadrillions of of computer operations
it might be something worth
investigating again and it's something
where you would then be directly
training in this discreet World which is
much more suitable for current
electronic computers
so I mean those are a few thoughts there
I mean I tend to think that the sort of
the idea of neural Nets there's a
there's a lot of uses of the idea of
neural Nets which we will yet see I
think in terms of the sort of the core
ideas uh well they've been surprisingly
sort of uh just being tweaked over the
course of many many decades I mean I
think it's sort of reminiscent of some
of what one saw in the history of things
like linear algebra you know there's
kind of this idea of matrices and
there's these operations you can do on
them of solving linear equations systems
and linear equations doing various kinds
of decompositions things like this in
the 1960s 1970s sort of computational
methods for doing those things really uh
kind of got established and that became
this methodology of doing numerical
linear algebra that was at first a thing
for its own sake
but then found lots of applications and
launched lots of areas like computer
graphics for example which makes very
direct use of numerical linear algebra
neural networks actually make direct use
of numerical linear algebra as well but
that's something where that sort of
methodology of numerical linear algebra
and all the Exotic Matrix decompositions
that we Implement in both language and
so on
um are things from that time and they've
been sort of incrementally improved but
basically it becomes a method that you
can use and apply in lots of different
areas and my feeling is that's what
neural Nets are becoming and and the you
know the dramatic uh sort of drama in
the core technology probably not so much
drama in the use cases that can be found
much more likely so that that's a a few
thoughts on that but I do think there
are some things that one can imagine
that are more kind of structural like
these things about a discrete version of
neural Nets possibly versions of neural
Nets that don't just involve numbers but
involve something more like symbolic
expressions or graphs or something like
this for uh for for the the for the
actual sort of data that the neural net
is dealing with things where there is a
better way found to have sort of
combination training and use of the
neural net things like this I mean
they've been all sorts of Adventures in
uh uh things like reinforcement learning
and so on which is sort of a an idea
that's been discovered and rediscovered
for 60 70 years or so between control
theory and machine learning and so on
um the idea where sort of the neural net
goes out and probes the world or probes
something that's trying to learn about
rather than you just saying okay here's
here's what you need to know
um rather it's going off and sort of
actively poking at things and so on and
uh uh and and um and seeing what and and
once giving sort of the world is giving
feedback to it those are techniques that
are that are useful but I don't know I
don't think there's something sort of
truly transformative that I don't think
that's around the corner there
let's see
uh
Luis comments you know that could evolve
to be able to be trainers what are the
limits strainers of humans trainers of
neural Nets I mean one of the things
that is certainly an interesting kind of
thing that builds up a little bit like
our civilization builds up you know in
our civilization you know one generation
discovers certain kinds of things and
then subsequent Generations get to make
use of that knowledge to build on that
knowledge so it is with neural Nets you
know when when one has had sort of one
neural net kind of has figured out
things about image recognition or
something you can build on that with the
Next Generation there are a couple of
different ways you can build on it one
is to use kind of the features that one
neural net recognizes and to say okay
rather than looking at the whole image
just look at these features when you
want to do the next level of processing
that's a place where you can almost do
sort of a brain transplant of when
you're on that you kind of chop off the
let's say the last layers of the neural
Nets you leave leave these sort of this
thing that represents the kind of where
the activity of the neural net
represents kind of the features it
discovered then you start training from
there that's kind of one way in which
sort of a new generation of neural net
can learn from the last the other is
something more direct where you say okay
uh we're trying to learn we're trying to
generate training data for a new neural
net let's use the existing neural net to
generate sort of boatloads of training
data for the new neural maps and that's
something people are interested in doing
for large language models
um there are other cases like for
learning about you know how to do
self-driving in cars where you really
want the car in addition to experiencing
the real world you want to be able to
make it experience kind of a video game
world and for that it's useful to to
think about having that Video Game World
kind of learn from things in the real
world and then sort of Leverage that up
for the next for the Next Generation so
to speak that's one one sense of this
the other thing is having neural Nets
and AI in general large language models
and so on be used as ways to help train
us humans and I think that's a very uh
very sort of uh
productive direction in which to go I
mean I think that there's both
much more personalization that one can
imagine and there's also much more
ability for for large language models to
learn learn how it is that we learn and
learn for each individual person what
the sort of map of their knowledge is
and the things that they are not
understanding and if only you told them
this they would understand it I think
it's it's promising I I don't know yet I
mean we've been doing a bunch of
experiments on this
to to make it so that you can make a a
large language model or an AI system in
general that will be sort of an optimal
teacher for a particular human and will
optimize both keeping the attention of
that human keeping that human motivated
and actually figuring out given the
thought patterns of that human what kind
of what you can uh you know what is the
right thing to say to that human to help
them over the next over the next Hill so
to speak to over the next barrier to to
let them understand a new thing so I
think those are those are sort of
directions now an interesting question
is just how successfully can we humans
be taught
you know we have our whole system of
Education you know most people go to
sort of schools where there's kind of a
broadcast form of Education of you know
one teacher and some number of tens of
students and so on
um some people you know do one-on-one
learn things one-on-one with Tutors or
whatever else and that's probably a more
efficient way to learn certain kinds of
things
um I think you know there's it's
complicated because there's also a
dynamic of uh being able to discuss
things with other people you're learning
with and getting the motivation from
other people being around and so on so
it's it's sort of a mixture of things
but I think this question of just how
fast can we humans learn something
here's an interesting question and you
know in in my own life I've tried to
learn lots of kinds of things I think I
gradually over the years have gotten
faster at learning things but that's
mostly because I've learned lots of
other things before and because new
knowledge that I'm trying to get usually
fits into existing knowledge and so
that's kind of allows me to to sort of
Leverage What I already know to be able
to more quickly learn the new thing but
there's sort of a question of if there
was a an AI Based Teaching system that
when I want to learn topic X it knows
kind of what I know and it can tell me
the exact five things that I need to
understand to really sort of get on top
of that new topic I kind of feel like it
often is the case that there are a
limited number of new ideas but one just
has to really grok that new idea and I
might be get it very quickly or I might
be like I don't get it I don't get it I
don't understand it kind of bashes up
against some other ideas some other
thing I knew I don't understand it seems
inconsistent with that it seems
inconsistent with the intuition that I
have whatever else but if one had an AI
that kind of knew me well one could
imagine it basically saying look you
know this seems incompatible with the
intuition that you have about this or
that but here's why it isn't or whatever
else or even just you know the reason
why you're having trouble with this is
because it is incompatible with this
piece of intuition you have you know I
know from my own efforts to try to
explain things as I try to do on these
live streams there are all kinds of ways
that one can one learns about sort of
explaining things to people for example
one of the things that is perhaps not
obvious is when there is something
that's sort of a big idea something that
is a very surprising intuitional point
something like this if you just tell
people this is how it works bloomp
people won't guess it I wouldn't guess
it if somebody did that with me either
you really have to kind of uh sort of
signpost what's going on say look this
is surprising this is a big deal this is
something that's going to be hard to
understand you've got to kind of say
there's something difficult coming and
then people have a much better chance to
be able to understand that than if you
just say oh by the way blah blah blah
um and and you know that's just one of a
zillion different examples which
certainly you know good teachers learn
how to do these kinds of interactions
and you know can an AI be better than
any teacher at better than any human
teacher at being able to kind of inject
knowledge into us I think quite possibly
the answer is yes and that will kind of
it changes the economics and sort of the
calculus of Education quite a bit uh you
know it how long does it really take
to learn Advanced topic X and how much
kind of back and forth do you have to
have to really cement those ideas in
your mind and so on
let's see
uh
desk comments it seems like every decade
scientists keep saying we just realized
that brains DNA Etc are a lot more
complicated than we realized
uh
how close are we to actually
understanding them do I anticipate this
kind of it's really more complicated
than we expected continuing
most of the time that's been the case in
biology that people say oh my gosh we
turned over another rock and there's
just an incredible amount of stuff
crawling around underneath and it's more
complicated than we could possibly
imagine there are some cases where that
didn't happen
for example in the I mean the two big
theories of biology natural selection
and sort of the digital
uh content of of genomics those are two
very simplifying Kinds of Kinds of
discoveries which sort of went from oh
there's all these different things going
on and then we pulled it all together in
a theory then in the case of genetics
there are all these different things
going on but then we pulled it together
in a theory by the way another case
where that happened was when people
realized that there are only you know I
don't know 30 40 000 genes that are
relevant to sort of the biology of us
humans oh it's so few you know how could
so few programs effectively make
something like us
uh that was kind of in a sense I view
that as being a little bit like the
realization that uh I've uh you know
importantly kind of worked with a lot
which is that even very simple programs
you know computational systems can do
very complicated things that's kind of
biology showing the same kind of
phenomenon that actually the underlying
laws are not as complicated the
underlying rules the underlying genetic
programs are not as complicated they're
not as many they're not as complicated
as you might have thought to make
something like us
but so I think the reason that biology
keeps on seeming more and more
complicated is that we don't have a good
theory for it now you know could it be
the case that there is no theory that
it's all kind of computational
irreducible and they're just running
these rules and then it happens to come
out this way
my guess is that there is actually there
is a potential for theory in biology and
part of the reason I say that is that
biology at some level the things that
happen in biology make sense to us
that's sort of inevitable we are we are
that biology and it's not like we have
this sort of random sensory system that
senses things we can't tell what it's
sensing no we have eyes and we have a
good narrative description of kind of
how seeing works and so on so we've
already managed to sort of define
biology to be something for which there
is at least an overall narrative about
what's going on
so now the question is if we look kind
of at the level of molecular biology can
we start seeing what's going on or does
it just look like every time we look at
something else it looks more and more
and more complicated
uh I think I I like Maps give an analogy
to this which I think is is interesting
which is physics
you know back in the 1600s you know
people like Descartes were saying you
know it won't be long before we have the
final fundamental Theory of physics
and uh the um
but it didn't pan out that way instead
what happened was you know looked like
things were pretty good at the time of
Newton we've just got these laws of
mechanics and it's all going to work and
law of gravity and so on and then things
started getting more complicated and
there were more different kinds of laws
et cetera et cetera et cetera and then
we got into sort of this level of stuff
and you know quantum mechanics came
along in the 1920s and so on and it
seemed more difficult for us humans to
understand it seemed there was more and
more complexity than we got particle
physics we've got all these different
kinds of things in Quantum field Theory
it seemed like the hope to find sort of
to to push through all of that and find
a truly fundamental Theory of physics
looked unpromising I mean what happened
in physics tended to be we thought we
had a theory that worked pretty well
like Newtonian mechanics but then there
were little glitches found and then that
was kind of a sign that actually there
was a there was a lot more underneath
and and then as we as we kind of probed
that it seemed like things got more
complicated than mathematical formalism
got more complicated and so on now the
fact that the mathematical formalism is
more complicated to deal with is
different from saying it is
fundamentally a more complicated
structure and I think much more what
happened is it got more complicated to
deal with not necessarily that the
fundamental structure was more
complicated but as we've learned from
our physics project last few years it
looks very you know at this point I
consider it kind of certain that in the
end physics and the universe is sort of
computational at the bottom and there
really is an end to this process of oh
you look at another level and then
you're going to see something more
complicated and you're going to see an
exception to the things you discovered
before and so on no in physics it really
seems like there is a bottom level there
is an underlying computational machine
code so to speak to the universe and we
can actually get to it and sort of
exciting that at this time in history we
managed to get to the end of that
process well okay so what's going to
happen in biology
well I think in biology we kind of know
what the underlying underlying machine
code is it's basically physics chemistry
and so on but then the question is well
how does that get organized to make a
thing that is a living system
well the thing that has been noticed is
people keep on thinking oh the narrative
we have right now is sufficient you know
Immunology works this way it's only this
number of different types of I don't
know white blood cells or something or
the brain works this way it's just uh
this and that is is connected and so on
and then you look in more detail and you
see more things going on now actually I
have to say one thing about brains
the very fact that chat gbt works
is a fascinating fact about brains
basically it's telling one this thing of
generating language which has always
seemed like a very difficult human thing
actually this artificial neural net
that's made in this very kind of formal
way is pretty good at doing that so it
tells us that yes there's a lot of
complexity in brains but a lot of it
doesn't really matter to being able to
to do this operation of generating
language so that's already a very useful
fact now you know does it if you want to
explain something about some particular
aspect of you know how brains react to
eating more sugar or something like this
that's quite separate from does it
really matter to the operation of brains
does it you know are you able to
abstract from from thinking about the
details of brains the things you need to
be able to produce language
I think
the uh sort of one of the features of of
molecular biology things like that is
well I remember when I was a kid for
example there were these wall charts of
the the metabolic pathways of the cell
and they were you know they were wall
charts but they were fairly modest in
size they could sort of Imagine uh you
know kind of there with a Krebs cycle
and this cycle and the and so on you
could kind of you know it was easy to
kind of sort of more or less get them
all in mind
now you can get these sort of metabolic
signaling pathway charts there they're
much bigger they're much smaller print
and they're many you know they're
multiple panels and so on there's a lot
more that's known there's a lot more
sort of complexity that's been
discovered in biology
and there isn't an organizing a set of
organizing principles around that in a
sense the sort of the chat gbt story is
telling one what are the important
things about brains to know what are the
important things about biology in
general I don't think we really know
those at this point
and I think that when it comes to sort
of what do the molecules actually do
well they're they're dancing around they
have all these ways of interacting with
other molecules it's all rather
complicated is some of that interaction
just kind of random the molecules are
sort of bouncing around randomly or is
it heavily orchestrated where there are
specific molecules with specific shapes
that specifically transport things in
this in that way I think it's
increasingly looking like the whole
thing is much more orchestrated what is
the theory of that orchestration we
don't know yet I mean I have some ideas
myself that actually come out of some of
the formalism of our physics project but
thinking about kind of how to think
about the general operation of a of a
biological system how to you know what's
really going on is it just a bunch of
molecules bouncing around having
chemical reactions or is it something
where you really want to unroll in a
sense the space-time graph of all the
different interactions all the different
events that occur between between these
molecules maybe there's a theory about
what happens when you look at this whole
space-time graph maybe that thing has
some regularities in it that we can make
a narrative about and that are really a
story not so much about this is the
molecule that exists and it has this
pathway that connects to that but
something more detailed that at first
might seem kind of dauntingly complex
but in the end we'll have some kind of
large-scale story associated with it I
mean a little bit like you could have
said oh DNA it's a very long molecule
you know you stretch that molecule out
it's a it's a meter long if we were to
pull a single molecule out and oh that's
just so much stuff it's so complicated
we'll never have anything to say about
it but in the end we have kind of this
uh you know important fact about its
digital information everything is
operating digitally and it's being
copied and so on and that allows us to
make some pretty General conclusions
about about biology and I think um uh
you know it depends a little bit what we
mean by understanding things so for
example in the case of AI and brains I
think we can say that even if we don't
know sort of even if we can't talk about
every biological detail of how language
generation let's say works we do know a
lot at this point about sort of the big
picture the big kind of computational
architecture of how that can work
so in the case of the rest of biology so
to speak it's like well what would what
would be a sign that you kind of knew
the big architecture of what's going on
I mean there are there are things about
biology like Aging for example sleep
even very fundamental basic things about
our experience of the world uh where
it's surprisingly uh obscure what's
actually going on I mean there are
different theories and there are some
features of them that are well known and
so on but you know is there a big
picture is there a fundamental theory of
of how aging works for example is there
a fundamental theory that proves that
you could never reverse aging is there
something that you know is there some
computational irreducibility argument
that says aging is inevitable and
there's nothing you can kind of do about
it or is that not the case is it just
some strange evolutionary adaptation to
to winnow out the old folk because
they're just a drag on on the on the
community so to speak you know and just
something where you flip the switch and
pretty soon it it uh that that feature
of sort of the degradation of biological
systems goes away we don't really know
and but I think there's sort of this
question of can you have a theoretical
framework in which questions like that
can be can be answered and that would
make it seem like biology wasn't just
detail detail detail detail detail and a
never-ending collection of details where
we we never get to the bottom of things
again I think it's a little different
from the physics case where sort of what
was happening there in terms of probing
further down in sort of the hierarchy of
what can be looked at a little different
in biology we know what's at the bottom
it's just atoms and molecules and things
and we know the physics of what goes on
there but this question about sort of
what's the what's the sort of overall
picture of the organization is it is
that I think the place that's that's
significant there I mean it is shocking
I think I mentioned this before that you
know over the time I've known a little
bit about biology the the level of sort
of uh amount of detail that's been
discovered about actual biological
systems has so unbelievably dramatically
increased through experimental methods
through more emphasis on biomedical
research and so on but the extent to
which the theory has expanded is very
very negligible I mean there's there's
people the the the the the sort of
traditions of the field are all about
doing experiments see what happens do
the statistics of what goes on oh
there'll be a bunch of Randomness we'll
never be able to say this is the
fundamental answer it's only there's a
certain probability for this to be the
answer Etc et cetera et cetera and so
there's been sort of a I would say a
prejudice against the idea of grand
theories of biology because there
haven't really been many I mean the last
big one was kind of digital structure of
DNA and that's from 1953. so the uh but
I think it's it's an area ripe for big
theories I tend to think that the best
hope for the sort of next round of big
theory is this idea of multi-computation
that's emerged from our physics project
and I hope I'll have a chance to pursue
some of this and and figure out perhaps
some things about biology and sort of
these these big picture answers about
biology which I think have been rather
elusive
let's see
uh
gosh riff comments about the Dynamics
behind crowdsourcing have interested me
they say for a long time
uh
can we start seeing its potential and
has the same principles as neural Nets
and so on I don't know crowdsourcing is
one of these things which to me
is
sometimes
a bit of a it's complicated it's sort of
a it can be a bit of a wimp out it can
be not as great as it seems I know and
sometimes it can be quite successful the
general principle that I've seen and
this is more a comment about kind of
business Affairs than uh than it is
perhaps about uh science and so on but
um
when there's a very well-defined set of
things to do
people sort of a a large crowd of people
has a much better chance to be able to
do it you just tell people uh go you
know if you've given a framework
people have a much better chance to be
able to contribute within that framework
and you know a lot of things where
people say it's the crowd it's you know
it's going to the crowd's going to
figure it out when you really peel back
the covers it's 50 people
or it's 20 people or even less
and you know it's in one of the things
about crowdsourcing can be if there
isn't really leadership about what
should be done
it's very hard for it to achieve
anything once there is sort of a
well-defined the leadership has defined
this is the box that every contribution
has to fit into has a better chance to
be successful but still uh you know it
it and I haven't looked so much in
recent years but in the past I did look
at just how big are those crowds that
are contributing I mean whether it's
Bitcoin miners or Wikipedia editors or
whatever else just how big is that pool
and it usually turns out to be a lot
smaller than you'd imagine
to down to tens of people and so on tens
of organizations
and it's uh uh you know I think that
certain kinds of things people find just
fun to do and uh so there they will sort
of do them for fun just for the fun of
the thing itself sometimes there's you
know in successful cases there's kind of
a community Spirit that's developed
where it's not just fun in and of itself
to do independently but something where
it's sort of fun to participate with
other people in I don't know I I think
um uh I've I don't know maybe they're a
sort of uh uh ways to organize sort of
groups of people that we haven't yet
discovered
um that uh uh that will be very
productive and I don't know whether
there's anything that one learns from
neuron that's about that you know the
very traditional view of how to organize
people is a hierarchical kind of
organization where they're sort of
because you know vision and Leadership
tends to be something that in individual
people can do different people will do
differently but if you say let's put
together 10 people to all be the leaders
and let's make the average of what those
10 people do it's usually not as good as
what any one of those people might have
been able to do by themselves or as good
in if if you want to have anything new
happen in the world if you want to sort
of Simply say don't let's have anything
new happen let's just keep the status
quo then having that sort of average
might not be a bad thing but it's um and
so you know there's the sort of
hierarchical organization of of things
and then their experiments people do on
sort of very different organizational
structures uh you know there was one
that was this holocracy idea where you
have kind of these intersecting Circles
of people I think has not been very
successful I think it's sort of uh
actually kind of disastrous in certain
cases
um where sort of there really isn't
anybody in charge and everybody's kind
of in intersecting Circles of who's who
is responsible for what
um I mean as a person who's in practice
run organizations for oh much of my life
um I uh you know it's hard enough to run
an organization where you can kind of
Define a vision and try and get that
executed but to run an organization
where you've got these intersecting
Circles of of uh thoughts about what to
do seems Seems just setting yourself up
for for uh absurd difficulty
so I don't know that's interesting
question whether there are forms of sort
of human organization that work better
now I think one of the things to realize
is that history tends to suggest that
there are certain sort of natural forms
of organization human organization that
work well with the Human Condition there
are ones you can scientifically imagine
where you sort of say well we can just
use mathematical principles to optimize
how we produce things and you know use
linear programming and optimization to
to work out how everything has to work
history has not been kind to those kinds
of Innovations history tends to say that
that sort of attempt to fit kind of
mathematicization on top of kind of the
way people should do things hasn't been
terribly successful uh whether that
means there's no better thing one can do
is I it's certainly not clear to me
whether for example with AIS as
intermediaries it's possible to have
different forms of human organization I
don't know I mean it kind of relates to
things like you know can we have a
democracy 2.0 where everybody writes you
know instead of voting for things
everybody writes a prompt and you feed
it all into a big Ai and ask it what to
do that doesn't really if you try and
unravel that it'll be interesting to try
and do things like that in practice
because I think one would learn a bunch
of things a lot of things would go wrong
but one would learn a bunch of things in
practice which even in sort of
theoretically thinking about it are not
obvious and you know quite quite often
in these kinds of you come up with some
scheme and you can say that scheme's not
going to work because of this effect and
that effect and then you realize that in
practice nobody runs into that pothole
you know in practice it works just fine
I see that a lot in design of
computational language for example there
can be this sort of pothole there that
uh this this some that you might fall
into but it turns out which we might
theoretically why worry about it turns
out nobody does so it doesn't really
matter and yet there are other cases
where you say it's going to be great
but then you're ignoring something which
ends up being this abrasion that
eventually makes the whole thing fall
apart and that's what a lot of these
kind of sort of schemes for better
organization of uh human interactions
and human governance and so on have have
had a pretty bad historical record now
of course we have new ingredient now
which is sort of better working Ai and
perhaps there are new things that can be
done there and that's an interesting
thing to to start thinking about um
working out
let's see
gosh robot is asking how do you
anticipate biotechnology future is
shaping the future of biomaterials and
tissue engineering and thoughts on
accessibility and affordability of
biotechnology and uh equitable
distribution of benefits you know this
whole question about what's expensive
and what's cheap in the world is kind of
interesting I mean when I was younger I
as lucky enough to have access to big
fancy computers that allowed me to do
things that your average person couldn't
do because they didn't have access to
big fancy computers at this point mostly
the computers that I use are just the
same as the computers that a billion
other people use they're really uh
there's no sort of computers got cheap
enough that they sort of are very widely
distributed now I have to say I I just
bought a fancy GPU that's a little bit
above the um uh for a particular project
I'm doing a little bit above the average
but that's the first time I've had
something fancy like that that I
remember in a couple of decades
um the uh
the thing that um uh you know the this
fact that consumer electronics became
cheap
with something or Electronics in general
became cheap was something I'm not sure
that it was super easy to predict
could it have been the case that that
there was the perfect chip that was
really big that could be produced but
there were only very very few of them
you know I remember seeing this muscle
in mid-1980s seeing large flat panel
displays
um and it's like okay these things exist
they will become common but it took
another 20 years for them to become
common because when you make a display
you have to have a yield that's good
enough that that sort of every pixel on
the display works perfectly if any pixel
doesn't work well it looks really goofy
on your on your television or whatever
because there's this kind of this dead
spot on your television and so that
wasn't a viable thing you could sell so
there was this sort of surprising extra
time and it was the case that you could
buy flat panel displays but they were
really expensive because you had to
produce a lot of them to get one that
was perfect
so this question of of what ends up
being expensive what ends up being cheap
it's complicated question you know the
in in electronics things have become
cheap and become pretty widely
accessible as a result of that now in in
things like drugs uh you know you make a
chemical you have a process for making
the chemical often that process actually
is quite quite cheap to implement on a
per unit basis but then the issue has
been well the way the world is set up
kind of the sort of Regulatory
Compliance of setting up the drug and
testing it and so on that's super
expensive so you know by the time you
spent billions of dollars on that the
drug can't be cheap at least not for a
long time because you're still paying
off those billions of dollars and by the
way you're also even sort of paying
forward because you're saying but we
want to develop new drugs and each one
of those is going to cost billions of
dollars so we kind of got to make the
money to develop those new things by
selling the existing things even though
the actual unit price of making that
stuff has gone down to be really low so
that's I think more a question of sort
of how the world is set up and and the
sort of trade-offs about testing and
buses deployment and so on it's not an
intrinsic expensiveness to those things
when it comes to kind of uh
biomaterials things like this uh the the
question of you know when one has 3D
printable organs and so on which will
happen I've seen a nice example of a 3D
printable 3D printed lung and uh you
know there'll be things like this lungs
actually harder than many other organs
but were prioritized for various reasons
the um uh it's you know that stuff will
come and uh will it be expensive will it
be cheap my guess is that it should be
fairly cheap
um it there's nothing about it that says
oh you know it's you can only mine this
number of diamonds type thing or you can
only you know there are only this number
of diamonds to be found you can you know
you make once you've got that 3D printer
that can print at sufficiently high
resolution once you've got these
processes for feeding in stem cells and
so on you can go into mass production
and there should be great economy of
scale now the question of of what is it
going to take to do these things there
are different approaches to biomaterials
one is the sort of 3D printing additive
manufacturer type approach which seems
quite promising I mean essentially
you're making a scaffold and then a
scaffold with inorganic materials so to
speak and and then you're adding in uh
various kinds of cells that sort of
arrange themselves on the scaffold and
that seems to be a pretty promising way
to do lots of kinds of Bio uh sort of
tissue construction and so on uh I think
there are other things one could imagine
one can imagine well another approach is
you just let the biology run its course
you start with stem cells you try and
figure out how to direct those stem
cells to differentiate to you know
usually I think for us humans it's maybe
15 levels of differentiation that
there's this whole tree of different
cell types there aren't that many cell
types maybe depending on how you count
it hundreds to thousands of cell types
and you know the question is can you
sort of give that sell the right pokes
to get it to differentiate to become you
know a pancreatic beta cell versus a
heart muscle cell versus whatever else
and you know can you just use the pure
biology to to be able to do that and
then if once you've got those cells can
you get them to organize themselves into
some structure that's useful as a piece
of tissue or do you want to you know
have a sort of non-living scaffold onto
which you assemble those things
um I I suspect there are there are
things to know about sort of how you get
cells to assemble themselves whether
you're using you know bioelectric type
methods or whether you're using some
other kind of way of getting the cells
to organize themselves or or putting
some appropriate chemical gradient in
there I'm not sure but those are things
that one can sort of Imagine doing then
of course there's a question of okay
you've got this this organ you created
or this um this piece of tissue you
created now install it well installation
in US humans is pretty hard and that's
sort of a story these days of surgery
and so on and while you know there are
there's plenty of sort of enhancement
from surgical robots and things like
that it's still a big complicated mess
of you know you poke holes in the in in
us or cut cut incisions and so on and uh
you know it's not a particularly easy
thing to do now there will presumably
come a time when you will be able to
like have sort of self-assembled things
delivered without sort of sticking them
through through a hole so to speak where
you could you know do something and this
is still science fiction where you're
kind of like okay just swallow that pill
and and then it has little Nanobots
inside it that go off and go and and
assemble themselves in the right place
in the body and uh and then all the
Nanobots start assembling themselves in
sort of self-assemble the thing you need
without having and sort of attach
themselves to the right place by the way
one of the supply amazing things about a
bunch of sort of stem cell therapies is
that you can just put various cells in
and they will find their way to the
right place where they fit so to speak
and and maybe biology will help us in
doing that maybe it's something where we
have to invent the sort of active
Nanobots that can figure out what to do
but I I think those are those are kinds
of things one can imagine
um as I say I think it's it's going to
be I suspect
um that it's more a question of kind of
governance than it is a question of
Technology whether these things end up
being cheap uh you know on on a unit by
unit basis
um and uh uh I think that's you know
that that's
that's a complicated societal question
how that's handled
um and uh sort of a mixture of of uh
economics and kind of social issues and
so on but I think that's the um
um
uh the the you know that's that's that's
the direction here
let's see
uh
Time cake says might be better to prompt
the body to regenerate its own organs
instead of 3D printing them
um given I think you're mentioning work
about bioelectricity and so on
um yeah that's quite possible I mean you
know so certainly amphibians managed to
regenerate limbs why can't we regenerate
things why can't we regenerate limbs for
example not clear
um and perhaps there is I mean the
program exists in our DNA you know the
DNA that makes us from the first you
know first uh sort of fertilized egg to
the whole of us the DNA that's being
used there is no different throughout
our lives so whatever was being used you
know in utero to make the first you know
to make the thing that produced that
piece of our brain that DNA still exists
and is still carried by us and will be
passed to the Next Generation and so on
so why can't we just activate that
program uh from our DNA and and remake
some particular thing as amphibians
managed to do I I you know I don't know
um and it's quite possible that a
technique will found to do that just
like you know people used to say I used
to ask for years you know for amphibians
it was known that one could make clones
and it's like well why can't we make
clones of mammals people say well it's
just very hard it's very hard it's never
going to be possible and then you know
then and when was it in 1990s kind of
Dolly the sheep got uh got made and
that's a weird process that involves at
some moment you know putting this
Electric
shock into the the the the the
um the cell and things like this and it
was sort of a technique that was found a
trick that was found that let one do
mammalian cloning and I think that's uh
yes I think it's quite possible that
though I mean I think in biology there
are going to be a bunch of tricks that
are findable so regeneration one
possibility my guess is cryonics there
will be a trick found that that
um let's go and do that I think aging
I'm less optimistic that there's a trick
so to speak I think that's more of a
kind of computational irreducibility
story that has sort of a uh that has an
infinite collection of things you have
to solve
um unfortunately but um I think um
uh anyway I think those are those are um
uh some thoughts about that
um okay maybe one more
thing I can look at here and then I need
to go back to my
day job here
uh Des is asking
is burrowing into an asteroid The
Logical way to Shield people on
equipment on voyages to say Mars or even
out of the solar system
well I don't know how hard it is to
burrow into an asteroid I mean I think
there was a recent uh experiment that
was done of an impact on a small
asteroid to try and figure out could one
sort of uh uh push the asteroid to
change its course so that if one detects
an asteroid that's on a collision course
for Earth you can kind of you know
thousands of years before it actually
collides with us and Earth and wipes us
out can you push it off course and so on
and I think that experiment worked
fairly well but that was the concept of
of setting up a whole kind of mining
operation to burrow into an asteroid
sounds kind of hard
um I it doesn't I mean it is a big issue
how do you Shield people and things in
in
interplanetary space
um because you know near the Earth we
have uh the van well we have um our
magnetic field of the earth
magnetosphere and so on and um we have
sort of protection from uh from cosmic
rays and so on radiation coming from
Mostly the sun if you're out away from
kind of the protective sheath around the
earth you're exposed to all those kinds
of things
um a thing I don't know the answer to
and should is I know people talk about
using water for example as a as a thing
that will shield radiation I don't know
I don't know what radiation depth you
need I know the the peak of the energy
Spectrum for charged particles from the
Sun is about one gev and I think that oh
let's see that's around minimum ionizing
yeah it's a good question how far does
that go in different materials as you go
to heavier as you go to things with
higher atomic number they will tend to
scatter those charged particles more but
you know carrying a bunch of lead on
your spacecraft is uh well it's very
heavy
um now of course the economics of of
what it takes to uh schlep you know a
very heavy thing into orbit are changing
fairly rapidly these days so maybe
that's not such an issue but you know
what kind of sheath you need to protect
you know us humans from the all these
Cosmic Ray Charles particles I'm not
sure I it my suspicion would be that
burrowing into an asteroid that the
technology you need to do that is more
difficult than what you would need to
sort of send the necessary sheath
um up into uh to just uh sort of create
it on Earth and launch it into space or
maybe maybe there as a way of mining its
components on the moon or something and
using that to uh to sort of you know
it's kind of it seems a bit kind of
old-fashioned to say let's build
ourselves a stone spacecraft so to speak
take lunar regolith or something make
bricks out of it and put it around your
spacecraft it's kind of will be a sort
of charming uh kind of old meets new
situation if the if the spacecraft going
to Mars or something ends up with a uh a
a stone exterior or something from from
Luna Stone I'm not sure if that's a a
viable way to do it
all right
well uh I think we should probably wrap
up there and I see lots of interesting
questions still to be addressed and I
will look forward to doing that another
time
so thanks so much and uh bye for now